but as you guys might expect this is my
last home game
I'm trying my yoga breathing but it's
not really working that well but this is
obviously super super emotional there's
just too many people to really thank
obviously Marc and the whole and coach
and old Mavs organization for for not to
only tonight for the entire 21 years or
all the fans have supported me
I've put you guys on a hell of a ride
with with with a lot of ups and downs
and you guys always stuck with me and
supported me so I appreciate it
of course thanks to my teammates who
supported me and I know it's been a
rough year for me physically but the
guys were always great and try to
support me and I've had so many amazing
I probably had around 200 teammates over
my 21 years and they were all great and
supported me and pushed me and so I'm
really appreciated it's too many to to
really name but I'm really appreciative
of all the guys that played with and of
course thanks to the Phoenix Suns for
staying out here and let me have a few
baskets tonight I appreciate it even
though
Jamal stole my show a little bit today
I'm a little mad at that
but not
anyway so I want to thank my family a
lot of people flew in from all over the
world a lot of them from from Germany my
dad's here my sister all sorts of people
so and anyways really speechless for
that but mark I think you want to say a
few words but it's been an amazing ride
and thank you guys so much for coming
out
[Applause]